yes well the number of women on the list
this year went up to almost 200 number
of people blow the age of 40 especially
in high technology of join the list and
you've got some unusual ones in your
country chris dawson is on the list and
new billionaire he did not learn to read
until the age of 27 and he's never read
a book and what this underscores is in
terms of doing big things in the world
it doesn't matter your background it
matters your grit and a little bit of
luck it's hope for us all then and steve
yes the more the richer you are more
complex your finances ours but how do
you go about actually measuring people's
well for this you go through a variety
of sources obviously publicly held
companies but you also look at the
assets who owns various buildings deeds
and the like you would talk to people in
an industry competitors you talk to
bankers investment bankers so there's no
one magic bullet on this it requires a
lot of people around the world
constantly digging and one of the
reasons that the number of billionaires
went up this year as we discovered a
number of new ones including involve
places of germany which now surpassed
russian the number of billionaires they
have over a hundred billionaires in
germany now wow that in itself is a
surprising statistic but it isn't always
people going up on the list is it
because some of the geopolitical changes
we've seen recently seem to have an
impact as well i'm thinking about the
situation in Ukraine because that's hit
some billionaires they're hard yes it
has including the president of Ukraine
got knocked off the list this year is a
chocolate maker and the turmoil in that
country is affected not only obviously
his country but also his own personal
wealth and so because you make it in one
year doesn't mean you make it the next
of Russia because of other declined
collapse almost semi collapse of the
ruble and their declining economy they
took a hit on the number of billionaires
this year India's now surpassed Russia
in that category for the first time ever
as i mention little better yeah yourself
have played a role in
tix as well you threw a hat into the
ring for the Republican presidential
nominations about talking about 2,000
1996 now weren't we but who've got your
money on for the Republican nominee come
next year still haven't been were
willing to place a bet or an endorsement
yet but Jeb Bush the former governor
Florida and obviously the Bush family
got out of the gate very early he hasn't
formally announced but he's doing
everything you do except an announcement
that's force others to scramble so his
name is out there Governor Walker
Wisconsin a lot of interest in the
Republican Party in him and you hear
other names like Huckabee and dr. ben
Carson a number of a governor's on the
Democrat side while former Secretary of
State Hillary Clinton is the formidable
frontrunner there's a lot of interest in
the left wing of the party in senator
Elizabeth Warren and Massachusetts if
she decides to run and she's given a
very little indication that you will but
if she decides to run she will be very
well financed and will have a lot of
enthusiastic supporters so they're going
to be a lot of fireworks in the next 12
to 18 months in our political